la parole est à monsieur charles ange
ginésy sur le premier ministre
le dernier rapport de la cour des
comptes sur le budget de l'état en 2014
fait le constat sévère d'un déficit qui
augmente de 10,7 milliards d'euros avec
une réduction des recettes nettes et une
augmentation des dépenses du budget
général monsieur le premier ministre ce
déséquilibre budgétaire a traduit
l'échec total de votre politique
or depuis trois ans vous êtes au pouvoir
les chiffres sont toujours mauvais et
pire ils n'ont cessé de se dégrader et
vous êtes seul responsable vous étouffer
l'économie de notre pays l'ump hier les
républicains aujourd'hui les élus locaux
les français vous demande chaque jour de
changer de politique après le temps des
écrans de fumée mariage pour tous
réforme territoriale qui ne répondent en
rien aux urgences et aux difficultés du
moment vient le temps de la loi
maquereau ou de la transition
énergétique qui par manque de dialogue
sont vidés de leur contenu
au lieu d'être améliorée dans les débats
au delà du déficit
tous les indicateurs sont dans le rouge
une croissance nulle quasi nul
contrairement à ce que vous dites un
chômage dramatique plus 641 mille
chômeurs depuis l'arrivée du président
hollande
ce matin vous nous répondez avec cent
mille contrats aidés en masque un masque
augmentant le déficit et ne créons pas
d'emplois durables ce que les français
attendent des emplois des emplois par
des contrats de travail adapté doper nos
entreprises par une réforme radicale du
code du travail par une simplification
des démarches administratives votre
projet de dématérialisation
le choc de la simplification par le
numérique n'étant qu'un moyen
facilitateur qui de supprime en rien les
contraintes
alors les français subissent la tripe
plein 80 milliards d'impôts
supplémentaires quand est ce que vous
allez changer politique monsieur jean
asile
pour les termes que michel sapin
ministres des finances et des comptes
publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés veulent débuter
ginésy votre question vous l'avouerez
vous même était un peu fourre tout
j'aimerais répondre à certains aspects
qui me paraissent pas être conforme à la
vérité je voudrais vous féliciter de
lire les rapports de la cour des comptes
vous devriez d'ailleurs les relier aux
prélèvements au cours de ces dernières
années et vous en tireriez beaucoup
d'enseignements quant à la qualité ou
plus raclette mans l'absence de qualité
de la gestion de vos prédécesseurs
ici sur ces bancs et au gouvernement
mais disons les choses clairement
si vous lisiez les rapports jusqu'au
bout si vous lisiez les rapports de la
commission du foment été international
de l'oecd du haut conseil des finances
publiques est d'ailleurs présidée par le
premier président de la cour des comptes
que diriez vous si vous disiez la vérité
vous diriez les déficits en 2014 ont
diminué là où il n'avait cessé
d'augmenter au cours des années
précédentes en 2012
ils ont diminué en 2013 ils ont diminué
en 2014 ils ont diminué et en 2015 2016
ils continueront à diminuer là où vous
les aviez laissées à plus de 5%
nous serons les ramener à moins de 3% de
déficit par rapport au pib
deuxième chose monsieur le député la
question de la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques qui est fondamental car nous
ne pouvons pas continuer à diminuer lé
déficit diminue les impôts comme nous
avons commencé à le faire en 2014 et
nous continuons en 2015 et nous
continuerons en 2016
nous ne pouvons pas financer nos
dépenses prioritaires je pense en
particulier à l'éducation ou à la
défense sans maîtriser et diminuer nos
dépenses publiques et c'est ce que nous
faisons ce que nous avons fait en 2014
monsieur le député regardez les chiffres
par tous les bouts les dépenses de
l'état qui sont à la main du
gouvernement ont diminué de 3,3
milliards d'euros
c'est ça la vérité et nous continuerons
à le faire car c'est le seul moyen de
remettre la france dans le droit chemin
de la bonne gestion et donc
merci monsieur mis d'accord